- good evening mr. Scott spin whoa
I think for myself you can read about
the movies and reviews and analysis of
the movies but that's about me I was 15
when I left I was 15 when the movie came
out so average day I was still gonna
grab that we are growing up in communist
regime or at that point it didn't really
seem like a horrible thing but you
become more adult than you realize the
life is not so beautiful there the world
was on fire
74 United States big Cultural Revolution
but yet were looking at movie star of
their roots our past was past of
Collinwood past of the time period that
we really were not learning in school
the promised land was the land of
opportunities that we really didn't
experience in possibly enduring during
communist government we didn't really
learn about that period either we hear
that the reserved you know
intelligentsia that there was a liberal
world
we have a really knowledge of of that
particular period so the movie was to
some degree an eye opener for me because
I'd learn about history of Poland that I
was not studying in school and I think
bad an exception is infinity that
probably somewhere there I just sucked
his images in the storytelling and and
and became filmmaker due to his art of
making movies and his his ability to
make those movies to the course of two
different political systems too many
movies such as men of marble which was
just drama dating for me we all knew
about then justice that the lie and all
the stuff that were told but what you
see on the screen and be able to watch
the movie that
a lot of diversity which is very partial
moment so yes Promised Land
it's in Poland it's not here it's there